so my name is emery burger and this is
really loud I'll try to keep it quieter
is this okay all right great so um I'm a
professor at the University of
Massachusetts Amherst this is Joint work
with my two PhD students two of my PhD
students Sam Stern and Juan offmeyer
pizzorno at UMass
okay
click
this would be great if this worked yes
fantastic all right so hopefully
everybody in this room is familiar with
this family uh The Simpsons right so
it's 2022. um but uh The Simpsons have
been on the air for a very very very
long time
um and uh this is what they looked like
in the 80s uh they look very different
right it was a pretty scruffy uh not so
well developed family
and
I like this a little lower give me two
seconds
okay
so likewise computers have really
changed right so you know today uh you
can get an iPhone that's three gigahertz
with five cores a 64-bit processor six
gigs of RAM sits in your pocket but in
the 80s this is the kind of computer you
had right so back when the Simpsons
first came on the air you had a four
megahertz processor not gigahertz
megahertz uh 16 bits and you know 640k
of ram which as we all know was enough
for anyone right all right so so you
know being that computers were so
underpowered in the 80s this meant that
really you know this is true all the way
up through the 80s that uh you had to
build programming languages that were
very close to the metal so I like to
call these metal languages so the first
metal language is assembly of course
and that dates to 1949
um and then you had Fortran uh the first
optimizing compiler right so it was even
beyond your ability to program
um optimizations right it would do all
this great work
um eventually we ended up with C uh and
then you know the meanest of all C plus
all right uh so we have these metal
languages and this is what people
programmed in because performance was so
critical right so computers were really
slow you had to squeeze every possible
ounce of performance out and then as you
all may be aware we went on a 40-year
performance ride so what happened was we
went on this ride some people refer to
this as Moore's Law I'll talk about it
more in a second
but briefly transistors
that is feature sizes on chips just
started getting smaller and smaller and
smaller and you could just clock up the
processors as the signal propagation
length decreased and so this meant that
literally every year or two you could
buy new hardware and your software all
your programs would run twice as fast
so optimization was really not necessary
it just required a little patience and
you'd have a faster computer and so
people were like oh my God this is going
to go on forever this is fantastic we
don't even need to care about these
metal languages anymore let's build
programming languages that I like to
call the irrational exuberance languages
that assume that performance was going
to go up and up and up to the Moon right
forever
so this includes languages like tickle
TK uh R PHP Ruby and the subject of our
talk today python all right so so python
uh it looks like it's the most advanced
in this evolutionary lineup but you know
Homer's not really the Pinnacle of
evolution
um is a little plump uh not a very lean
mean fighting machine and so this
manifests itself in a number of ways so
when you're programming in a metal
language like C plus and you want to
know how big an INT is it's four bytes
let's say but in Python that'll be 24
bytes
and you might ask yourself why would
this be the case well it turns out that
python objects are really fat they
contain a lot of information they
contain like the type information they
contain a reference count they contain a
pointer and so on so you don't just get
a raw metal int you get a bunch of goo
with it Homer style all right um this is
true across the board for all sorts of
data structures so if you have a
dictionary of a list events rather
that's 24 bytes in C plus plus well it's
56 bytes in Python likewise a dictionary
from end to int is an empty dictionary I
should stress is 24 bytes in Python
today it's 64 bytes in uh in Python
compared to 24 and C so a little less
than three times as much this is a huge
Improvement by the way because in up
until version 3.6 it was 240 bytes
um which turns out to be just about the
weight of Homer Simpson
all right so uh so I've talked about how
plump python is but there's another
problem with python that you all are
probably familiar with uh when people
talk about python one of the things they
often notice is that it's slow uh it's a
very slow programming language and so
why is it so slow it's not just that
it's fat it's also slow and the reason
at heart is because these metal
languages are compiled right so they
produce really really fast code and you
spend a little time compiling them but
then at the end the code runs really
quickly however most of these irrational
exuberance languages started out as
interpreters and continue to be
interpreters which means they're very
slow and so I want to illustrate a
little bit of what's going on under the
covers
so here is a little python function that
adds one to a variable the to an
argument and returns it all right could
be simpler when you run a Python program
it parses your Python program and
compiles it to what are called byte
codes so byte codes are a machine
independent instruction set and then it
interprets these byte codes
and it has basically a giant interpreter
Loop so I'm not really expecting you to
be able to see you know what's going on
here exactly but you can see it's a lot
more than what happens with C code where
it just converts the ad into a machine
instruction right so the upshot is you
get easily 100 x more instructions
executed when you're running python code
then when you're running C code and when
you combine this with all the other
efficiency opportunities that are left
on the floor you can get pretty Extreme
Performance gaps
so if you take a Matrix Matrix multiply
algorithm the classic three loops and
you write it in Python just translating
that to C will speed up The Code by 40x
and then if you just do a few very
straightforward optimizations
reorganizing the the loop so that it's
optimal in terms of memory accesses
using parallelism using simdi you
eventually end up with a 60 000 X
performance Gap right and so this 60
000x performance Gap this is like raw
Python and on the far right is using you
know the Blas libraries from Intel or
something which happen to be
conveniently packaged into numpy which
I'll talk about in a minute
all right so what happened in 2010 in
2010 this ride ended sadly uh so it was
a great time uh fund was had by all but
essentially you can see you know there's
all these transistors and they kept
going up and up and you know the trend
seems to be continuing on the left right
so the transistor counts are still
increasing this is Moore's law right so
a lot of people talk about Moore's Law
as if it's about speed it is not about
speed it's about the density of
transistors
um and their growth and it turns out
amazingly we're still actually on this
path I mean it's got to stop someday
right I don't know the quantum level or
something but right now it's still
happening but you can see that it
totally flattened out on the right and
this phenomenon that used to allow us to
clock up these chips is called dinard
scaling and Denard scaling is what
really ran out of steam and well or it
could produce a lot of steam if you put
water next to one of these things
um because uh basically the chips got so
dense that it was impossible once you
clock them up above a certain uh
frequency to dissipate their heat so
it's not really fun if you're you know
there were all these graphs that they
would have in all these academic
conferences about how you know today
it's a it's like having a 110 watt light
bulb and then tomorrow and then the next
day it'll be like the surface of the sun
which is a really hot iPhone burn a hole
right through your pocket so so what
does this mean well guess what we're
still stuck with python we're more stuck
with python than ever it has a if you
will a Stranglehold on us it has become
the most popular programming language
but computers are no longer getting fast
so what do you do when you have slow
code
you find a profiler right so here is a
profiler this is a built-in profiler for
python it's called C profile
and this is a really typical result from
a profiler I love it it says that in
this particular code we're spending all
of our time in Maine
thank you profiler
very helpful
um so uh so this is not super useful
um there have been many many attempts to
come up with more useful profilers for
python
um this is just a collection of some
from the ecosystem there are more that
are not listed that I'm not going to
talk about in this talk but I want to
bring your attention to two of them
these are two variants of one called
yappy which is yet another python
profiler and there are many more that
have followed it so it's uh it's quite a
common thing to create a new profiler
because everybody is dying from
performance in Python today I will be
talking about a new profiler from our
group called scaling but it's quite
different from the others as you'll see
all right so first
um one this is not like the most obvious
thing I would say about profilers but
it's very important that your profiler
actually not slow down your program that
much the reason I say that is because
you've got a slow program on your hands
a slow Python program on your hands and
now you're going to profile it and if
that profiler itself slows down that
already slow program you're going to be
in a world of hurt right so
um there are some profilers that
actually do very well so 1.0 is the best
this is normalized to running the
original Python program this is for a
benchmark from the pi performance Suite
um which is a benchmark Suite that they
use to tune python
right so to the few that are pretty good
um there's a few that aren't great I put
these in yellow for caution this
includes the built-in C profile
um so the slowdowns range here from two
to seven X I should add as you'll see in
a minute some of these slowdowns also
translate to massive losses and accuracy
so the profilers will actually give you
wrong results partly because they're
slowing everything down in a weird way
it's biased all right so clearly you
would not want to run a profiler in this
yellow zone in production maybe in the
green zone but the yellow zone probably
not and definitely not the ones in the
Red Zone all right so um you know to
make this concrete the one that's almost
40x
um imagine if you had a program that
took a minute to run and now it takes 40
minutes
right that's pretty painful uh so for
most people this is unacceptably high
overhead which is why it's red but I've
saved the very best for last uh you have
to notice it so I'm going to go back for
a second the top here was 40. now the
top is 275. okay and so this is a
profiler called memory profiler that
slows down execution for this Benchmark
by almost 300X but we've seen higher
slowdowns for this profiler as high as a
thousand X
um and when I say as high as a thousand
X I mean I killed it after a thousand x
uh I couldn't wait anymore I had Life to
Live all right so it's important that to
note memory profiler is like it's not
like these other profilers all these
other profilers only profile a CPU
memory profiler naturally profiles
memory right so these are two totally
separate things that said you probably
want both but you only get one and if
you want memory profiling right now
using this profiler it's very painful
so I'm going to turn this into a form
that will be easier to see so I'm going
to rotate this and turn it into a table
so you might be asking naturally like
where does scalene fit in and it turns
out scalene imposes maybe 20 30 overhead
on average
um now I'm going to talk a little bit
about some details about these profilers
so uh profilers typically fall into two
categories these are basically CPU
profilers except for memory profiler
they profile either by function or by
line so at the function level right you
you see line numbers but those line
numbers just correspond to the very
first line in a function right and all
the information is aggregated over the
entire function so this is fine if you
have a lot of little functions but if
you have functions that are pretty big
it's not very useful right so if you
have a big long function
like here's a function and it says hey
this function took a long time and this
function is you know 150 lines of code
this is of scant use right it's like hey
look over there you're like where there
there over there somewhere there's a
function it's called big ass function
you figure it out all right so there are
other profilers that are operated at the
line level right and so this can be a
lot more useful
um it's especially worth noting that you
know in Python especially if you're
using numpy or or scikit or one of these
these packages
there's a lot of activity that happens
on a line of code right in C plus plus
one line of code probably is not
spending very much time but in Python it
could be spending an amazing amount of
time right like you know trained pytorch
model right so um you know there's a lot
of work that's happening there but if
you have a very large program it might
be a too fine to granularity right so
you know do we do function do we do line
and the answer is why not both right so
scalene does both uh it is a profiler
that handles both function level and
line level profiling fine all right
this one is totally crazy
um some profilers require you to
decorate the functions that you wish to
profile within at profile decorator
which is uh it's beyond annoying so you
put in this decorator you go through the
functions and you put them in but this
is weird right because it's like hey I
will happily profile for you why don't
you tell me where the functions are that
need profiling
it's like but I would like you to tell
me that
and it says no no no this is just fine
just put in app profile
um so this is a bit it's a pain anyway
just like changing your code but also it
puts the cart before the horse it's like
well somehow you already know well what
if you don't right then you're like
putting app profile app profile app
profile it's like print line debugging
but for performance all right so uh
scalene does not have this uh this issue
but it also supports that profile but in
a different way if you actually know
where you're looking for and you put an
ad profile then it'll only profile those
things but by default it'll profile
everything
all right
um what else threads so uh python has
threads kind of uh so most of you
definitely does have threads uh
concurrency is another question
um but uh as you probably know there's
this thing called the global interpreter
lock how many of y'all have heard of the
global interpreter log okay excellent
how many of you love the global
interpreter lock
one one liar raises his hand
um so uh so the obviously for CPU level
performance threading is not so great
but nonetheless there's stuff that you
do in Threads and python like to hide
you know the latency of network
connections for example and a number of
these profilers just fail entirely with
threads which to us was a big surprise
um it's like python has had threads for
a very long time but these profilers
don't support them fine
uh there's something even more
remarkable which is that um there is a
package called multi-processing so if
you want true parallelism in Python you
can't use threads because of the global
interpreter lock so you have to use
processes so there is a widely used
Library called multi-processing that
allows you to run parallel processes and
none of these profilers support them
which is like okay great like if you're
trying to get higher performance and now
you have a profiler no profiler will
help you once you embark on the really
high performance space so terrific all
right so these are not this is great
this is you know I'm we're happy that
scalene works with you know broader
subset of the Python language and
ecosystem but these features are not the
most important features
so it turns out that no pass profiler
does any of the things listed here on
the slide except for one which is that a
memory profiler also profiles memory but
as I'll describe we have the situation
where we can profile python versus C
time uh system time memory GPU memory
Trends copy volume and detect leaks all
at once and I'll talk about how this all
works all right the key observation
about python
that I think anybody who is looking to
improve the performance of their python
code needs to understand or probably
already understands is that python is so
slow your job as a python programmer is
to actually program NC
okay but what I mean is you program
using these libraries that are super
performant that are written in C C plus
or in the case of numpy Fortran at the
end of the day uh not a lie
um and uh you know that's where you're
going to get your performance right
because you have this enormous
performance gap between Python and C so
really your job is to find all the
python execution or the python memory
and root it out and move everything to
these libraries
all right so I'm going to talk about
scalene we call it scalene uh because it
has the word scale and it sounds like
lean but also because it has these three
legs it's a CPU profile or a memory
profiler and a GPU profiler
so if you take some code and you run
scaling with it you get a view like this
and I'm going to walk through a little
bit of what these this report looks like
so first it does CPU profiling when you
hover with your mouse over these bars it
shows you you know percentages and so on
and you can click on the top header and
it'll sort everything by CPU or by
memory and so on the breakdown is every
time you see a color that is dark that
means it's in Python and your goal is to
make things light right move away from
the Dark Side okay so it breaks down all
of your execution it says hey there's
python time there's native time and if
you look and you see native code and
you're spending a lot of your time in
native code congratulations right that's
you've done the right thing what you're
trying to do is to move everything out
into native land
it also shows memory consumption uh same
situation it's dark if it's python
memory and it's light if it's not it
presents average per line as well as
Peak per line so you can find things
that are really consuming a ton of
memory it also grafts memory usage over
time which can illustrate certain
patterns that reveal issues that are
going on so if you have something
growing and growing or zigzagging and so
on those are useful there's a global
view as well everything at the top is a
global summary of the same sort of
information including member usage over
time and we introduce a new metric that
we call Copy volume
so let me explain what copy volume is so
copy volume is measured in units of
megabytes per second and the what it
measures is how much copying is going
basically across the python and Native
boundaries so if you're using native
code it's really important like you know
once you're a native you stay native for
a long time and then come back with a
result but if you inadvertently take a
python data structure and send it to
something or you load something into a
python data structure you put it into an
array in Python it will say oh you would
like this in Python now and then it will
copy out everything into a gigantic
python data structure and then if you
then in your next iteration go and try
to run native code on it it's going to
then copy it back and write it in so
you'll be spending a lot of this time
and it's totally invisible right you
can't see that it's happening in the
source code and scalene is the first
profiler to reveal that this is
happening and if you spot it you want
this to stop so this is indicative
finally there's GPU profiling in this
case we didn't use the GPU if you have a
GPU it'll show with an Nvidia GPU it'll
show utilization and Peak memory all
right so let's dig in a little bit and
optimize this piece of code this is uh
some actual code that somebody sent us
where they're like I don't understand
why scalene is reporting this uh this
information and we're like no no it's
doing the right thing here's what the
issue is so you can see on the left a
bunch of performance like a bunch of the
time is spent in native code and I
already told you native code good right
so that seems fine
um here you can see there's two gigs
allocated in native code again native
memory is compact right that's the metal
representation super
um there's a lot of memory activity and
there's this weird Sawtooth pattern it's
a little hard to see but it's allocating
memory freeing memory allocating memory
freeing memory that seems weird right
that's not something you would expect
and most crucial of all is there's a ton
of copying there's 250 megabytes per
second of copying and basically once you
see this copying and this extra
allocation and you look a little closer
at this line of code
it's running some numpy and it uses this
NP dot array operator so np.array
converts its argument into a numpy array
so if you had a python array it would
then turn it into a proper you know like
array of Floats or array of doubles
right but it turns out that this thing
already generates a numpy array and so
what does NP dot array do you might
think it just casts it but you would be
wrong because at numpy np.array by
default is like whatever you give me I
will surely convert it to a numpy array
is it already an Empire array great
here's another one all right so that's
the allocation Sawtooth explanation it's
allocating a new copy copying the old
one into the new copy and throwing away
the old copy and it's doing this a bunch
of times and that's what leads to this
Sawtooth so what did we do Guided by
this uh this this Insight that we got
from scalene
we went and we got rid of the np.array
so we just deleted a few characters uh
and you can see that what happens it's a
little hard to see on the screen but the
uh the runtime dropped from 30 seconds
to 23 seconds and the Sawtooth pattern
went away and the copying went away and
the memory Peak memory consumption also
dropped right so this is obviously a
very small example but you can you can
see I hope how this kind of presentation
of this information can be useful right
you get this holistic view of everything
including this new metric and this can
reveal uh optimization opportunities so
one of the things we wanted to know this
is not our goal like we were like hey
scaling should be accurate right that
would be good it turns out many of the
profilers are wildly inaccurate you
would like everything to be along this
diagonal and scalene is just above it
together with two other profilers
the worst you could possibly be is
higher like way high above you know if
it was going from the uh the essentially
the y-axis and then over on the x-axis
that's the pass the worst possible
situation and one of the profilers
practically approaches it
the upshot of this is if you use a
profiler that's this inaccurate it will
actually tell you hey your program is
spending a lot of time here you can go
optimize it but it's wrong
right and then you'll optimize it you'll
waste that time optimizing and then your
code will still be slow and the profiler
will not have given you any useful
assistance at all all right so
um I also mentioned obviously execution
time so scalene scaling actually has two
modes it operates in if you only want to
do CPU and GPU profiling it's somewhat
faster than doing the full memory and
copy volume profiling so if you do that
it runs it essentially no overhead it's
like 1X here in this talk I'm just going
to talk about like with memory
consumption the memory analysis uh
memory profiler like I mentioned can be
easily 200x slower on this benchmark
um but scalene is also profiling memory
and it's like 1.2x so what's going on
like how is it that we're able to do
this so let me first tell you what
memory profiler does memory profiler
tracks every single Malik and free
uh python
occasionally allocates memory
right like all the time it's constantly
allocating new objects and tearing them
down it has a custom allocator designed
to make this fast but when you impose
tracking on every single one of those
it's very very costly
so every single time there's an
allocation memory profiler records Malik
info right Malik info it records the
free info records Malik info and so on
and you can easily see how this can be
very very expensive
so scalene actually adopts a new
sampling strategy where it it's
essentially a kind of threshold-based
sampling so it only tracks every time
the Delta of memory consumption so
whatever your high water mark is or your
current high water mark is as soon as
it's uh if it's like going up and down
and it's not crossing a megabyte
threshold there's no recording so let me
illustrate this with some maggies so
during this whole regime there's nothing
that happens you're just allocating and
freeing and allocating and freeing kind
of part of what python is just doing on
its own anyway you don't care if it's at
a stable point right if it's not really
consuming a ton of memory but once it
crosses that megabyte threshold it
records the Malik info and then it waits
until it goes up or down by another
megabyte and then when it does it'll
record Malik information again so unlike
most sampling approaches this is
actually precise like whenever you go up
and up and up you will catch all of that
memory consumption uh if you ever
allocate a very large object it will
definitely like if it's more than a
megabyte you're definitely going to
record it but most of the time it's like
a low pass filter it just filters out a
lot of the allocation activity and this
gives us high accuracy with very little
overhead right so that's how we get very
granular memory information for um from
with scalene with low overhead
let me talk a little bit about our
Jujitsu hack that allows us to get the
to break down CPU Time by python time
and Native time and also system time so
there's a thing that all interpreted
scripting languages from the 90s all the
irrational exuberance languages do which
is called deferred signal delivery so
what does this mean so it means that
when there's a signal like a timer
signal which is a thing that profilers
rely on right they go tick tick tick and
they send a signal python actually
hijacks all of these signals right so
the signal is actually always caught by
Python and then delivered it's a pretend
version of the signal in effect Perl
actually does this now it used to not do
it and it would periodically Break The
Interpreter there are very good reasons
for doing this deferred signal delivery
but it has some negative effects so
suppose you write a profiler and you
would like regular timing interrupts
right so every 100 milliseconds so if
you're running python code basically
these are delivered promptly
as it's interpreting bytecode in effect
every so many bytecodes it's going to
actually check and say oh are there any
pending signals and it'll deliver them
so as long as you're running pure python
this is fine however if you're running
native code the whole time you were
running a function call into native code
all signals are deferred
until you finally come back to python
all right so if you were saying hey I
want to see how much time I spent
running this code the whole time it's
executing native code it's effectively
comatose all right so you know uh the
the C like it's like I could spend a
year running C code and then I'll come
back and it'll be like oh only one
second has elapsed all right so this is
not exactly ideal it makes it a
challenging to write a CPU profiler but
it turns out that we can actually
leverage this
so we're going to turn lemons into
lemonade so what we're going to do is
every single time we take one of these
signal interrupts we're actually going
to record the time so we're going to
record the process time or the virtual
time and every time we come back we're
also going to record the time and then
we're going to compare them right and so
we're going to observe if we were
delayed why did we get delayed well it's
process time the only way we could be
delayed is because we're running code
right native code and so what we can do
is actually straightforwardly say every
time we get one of these interrupts we
accrue whatever the expected interval
was to python time and then we add delay
minus interval which is the waiting time
to Native time right this is a it's a
very simple equation it actually we have
a formal proof that this works so it
actually does what it's supposed to do
so you can take this to the bank
all right so finally I want to talk a
little bit about automatic memory Leak
Detection so memory leaks are an issue
in Python despite the fact that it is a
garbage collected language uh and people
I think think some people think
erroneously that garbage collection
prevents memory leaks it does not uh
because if you have a pointer into any
object and that object you forget about
it well that object can never be
reclaimed so that can lead to a memory
leak but it gets worse You're Now using
C code and the C code can also leak and
you can have cross-language leaks so
it's a very messy situation you can have
C code that's tying down a python object
all right so even a python-based leak
detector won't be able to find what's
going on because it's actually the
pointer is being held in the C state
that it doesn't examine I can't
so it seems like a hard problem uh we uh
we solve this problem in a kind of um
ground about way it involves Donuts
um so this is a talk like Simpson's
inspired so Donuts had to appear so for
every malloc we say Malik instantiates a
new donut
all right at that line uh and every time
there's a free Homer eats that donut all
right now you can see that if you are in
a steady state nice situation where
whenever the donuts appear Homer eats
them right we don't have a leak
all right so we're literally going to
keep track of in some way on a per line
basis the rate at which Donuts are being
created and the rate at which they're
being consumed
and if we discover hey there's a bunch
of donuts but there's not matching
homers we have a memory League All right
so we could do this by tracking every
memory allocation in every free but I've
already shown you that for memory
profiler that's a disaster right it
slows things down massively and we did
not want to do that so what we do
instead is we do a kind of random
sampling so we periodically randomly
choose allocations that we're going to
track and we say oh you allocated this
donut what is its address
and then we go and we check just when we
we invoke free hey was it this address
this is a very cheap check right it's
literally just a comparison the
comparison is generally false so it's
well predicted uh and if it detects that
this free there's a matching free for
the donut
right then it says great I'm gonna
increment account right so what we do is
in effect we start out with everything
getting one donut and one Homer uh this
is required so we don't do division by
zero all right uh and then we observe
for all the lines over time what's
happening with the donuts and the
Hummers so we count up the donuts and
the homers and we compare them and if we
observe a large enough number of donuts
and not enough homers we apply this
thing called laplace's Rule of
succession to conclude that this is in
fact a memory link
all right and so when this happens it
actually reports leak volume per line so
let me show you what this looks like in
the UI
here you can see underneath the little
memory timeline thing it says in red
possible leak and you know you can see
that the memory activity is going up
which could be legit but here it's like
ah this looks like a possible leak and
if you Mouse over it it says
there's a basically the probability has
to cross some threshold like 99 and
it'll report this and it says here's the
rate of leaking so it's leaking 0.3
megabytes per second so why is this
useful so obviously it's useful to track
down memory leaks right memory leaks are
bad but it's also useful because we
measure how severe the memory leak is
not all memory leaks are created equal
and if you have a memory leak where it's
like well this is only going to run for
an hour and it's you know 0.1 megabytes
per second or something do the math okay
we'll be fine we're not going to consume
too much memory but if it's you know 20
megabytes per second you're probably
doomed right so this gives you a way of
prioritizing this just by looking at the
rate of uh of memory leaking and
deciding what you're going to do with it
all right so I'm going to conclude
scalene is this new profiler for python
that does a bunch of things CPU
profiling memory profiling copy
profiling and GPU profiling it unlike
all past profilers it also well it works
for a bunch of python code that the
other password followers don't work on
but it also you know reports the
breakdown between native code and uh and
python code native memory and python
memory and this is very useful we
believe in getting decent performance
out of python you can easily install it
using pip or conda that was a journey
getting it to work with conda but anyway
there's a like 80 commit message chain
of me discussing with the condo people
like what now but anyway it's been
downloaded about 370 000 times to date
which is uh is nice you can go get it on
pip but the the GitHub site that is
there below is also in the QR code has
the information and how to use it and
other documentation and in some you know
we want to get out from the Stranglehold
of python but we still want to use
Python but we want it to be fast and so
hopefully we'll scalene will help us on
that journey and thanks for your
attention
[Applause]
right okay great question so the
question is uh I mentioned that there's
this sort of one megabyte threshold for
the sampling for memory profiling uh can
you change this uh and if not uh or even
if so why did you choose one megabyte so
it's actually closer to 1.5 megabytes
and it's actually actually a prime
number
um for reasons uh mostly having to do
with stride so if you're always
allocating the same amount of memory uh
it could end up triggering it all the
time and not not breaking it up in a
kind of random way
um
it is currently not configurable but we
have thought about making it
configurable but we're not going to put
in the complexity unless people are like
please please we really need it to be
configurable there's an obvious
trade-off between the amount of memory
that's consumed or the you know the
amount of memory that's sampled
um and then the accuracy and we felt
that something that's close to a
megabyte in granularity would be
intuitive for people that people like to
think about things in terms of megabytes
but of course in your world it might be
gigabytes uh and then maybe one megabyte
granularity is too fine but uh that's
that's the reason we chose that number
so great question
yeah multi-processing so the question is
uh you know tell me about
multi-processing and I guess the hidden
questionnaire is why why did why why is
it we're the only profiler to do it it
is not rocket science uh what we had to
do
um we had to insert ourselves in every
process that got launched uh so that we
were tracking it
um so we did this basically by hijacking
um exec
um and because you can do all these
crazy things in Python we did
um so so we did that so we track all
these spawn processes uh and then you
know they record all this information
all the profiles uh in temp files with
pids attached and then we aggregate them
so again it's not rocket science it's
just that I think people either didn't
know that they should profile it or they
didn't really think they didn't think to
try I'm not really sure but but in any
event we were like multi-processing
clearly important we should make that
work and that was all done by my student
Sam
uh are there practical tips this is the
question I think right are practical
tips or or uh hints or Pro tips for uh
for not screwing up performance with
python uh yeah
um so uh Loops are bad
okay uh that sounds really simple you
know what else is bad comprehensions so
list comprehension is also bad those are
just Loops
um they're they're expensive Loops
um anytime you're spending a lot of time
in Python and you're doing iterations or
you're doing this generation in Python
that's going to kill you uh and so for
numpy the trick is to always do
vectorized operations
um you know you do these broadcast
operation stuff that all happens in Sea
land so you want to keep this as much of
the sea stuff happening in Sea land and
Loops are almost always a bad sign
that's an anti-pattern
great question yes
so the question is hey yeah yeah you're
writing python code but you're you know
really you're you're not writing python
code uh I I view this as sort of a Fight
Club thing right like it's like first
rule of python Fight Club is there is no
python Fight Club right so you're not
supposed to program in Python to the
extent possible but you know that's
overstating the case right the fact is
is that there's like every Library Under
the Sun has python bindings like all of
them right and you know maybe some of
them have Java bindings and some of them
have other bindings but boy they all
have python bindings and so if you want
to get [ __ ] done I'm being recorded oh
well uh uh then you know python is the
way to do it but you also want to be
careful and the problem is it's very
easy to get bitten by these performance
issues because you're just like writing
and connecting things up and you write
in a kind of reasonable way that may or
may not be good enough and for
prototyping it's fantastic but you know
I can tell you that when you actually
turn this into real code so this is a we
have an issue for 6 stories that was
inspired by Julia Evans
we would just asked people to post their
success stories and so this was from
somebody at semantic scholar and you
know this is these are sophisticated
people uh but they're doing a bunch of
machine learning I mean I'm not bud and
they're doing a bunch of machine
learning and of course they're using
these machine learning libraries but um
you know they needed to be able to find
out what was going on and what was
taking their time and they basically
were able to get their costs down by 92
percent
which is to me insane but you know
there's so much low-hanging fruit in
Python because it is so slow so if you
can root out all the python stuff you
can really have a big impact it's a lot
better like when I talk with folks in
native land and C plus right people like
yes we got a five percent performance
Improvement five percent right you know
it's in Python you get rid of some
python you get you know 5x performance
Improvement
um you know I have student a student who
reported that uh improving their numpy
code they got a 20x Improvement right uh
driven by scalene saying oh hey this is
what you really should be looking at so
so I'm in violent agreement with you is
really what I'm saying
all right thanks very much for your
attention I'm happy to talk
[Applause]